boris johnson and the government soon
realized
very early on i mean it was was around
the time of the first lockdown in march
we have to go with the media consensus
on this
because if we don't go with the media
consensus on this we are
going to be slaughtered on a daily basis
and we are going to be blamed for
every single covert death in this
country
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantly kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today is a male online columnist
and a presenter on gb news dan wooden
welcome to chicken launcher hello
it's so good to have you on the show the
roles are reversed because usually i do
your show on thursdays you're here today
it's great to have you on
now you're asking the questions this is
terrifying
dear and headlights moment for you but
listen it's so great to have you on the
show we've got lots of questions for you
but before we get to them
tell everybody about your background who
are you how are you where you are what's
been your journey through life that
brings you sitting here talking to us
the journey words the journey word uh
well i guess my
my background is quite unusual maybe in
terms of where i ended up because
i was born in new zealand so i'm a
dual british new zealand citizen because
my
grandparents well my my parents were
actually born here
my mom was born in essex my dad was born
on an army base in malta british army
base in malta
but they were part of the wave of ten
pound poms
who emigrated to new zealand after world
war ii
to start a new life away from rationing
and all of that sort of thing
so i was born in new zealand first
generation
and um moved here when i was 21
years old with no money in my pocket
i didn't know a soul so
i guess i was a genuine outsider to
this world and the world of the media in
the uk
but i had a lot of ambition and i really
wanted to
succeed on on fleet street as a
journalist
and that's what i really put everything
into so
i started working in financial
journalism actually when i came over
that was my first job once i was finally
able to get a job
having absolutely no money whatsoever
but i was just so determined i want a
job in journalism no matter what it is
so i worked for a
newsletter called futures and options
week it was about the derivatives market
and i knew absolutely nothing about it
and i
hated it but it was like my
route into journalism um and then i
worked for broadcast magazine which was
a big trade magazine for the tv industry
and that still exists today and
from there i went on to news of the
world which i guess was my big
break in journalism in the uk
and since then i've worked for the sun
i've worked for uh the mail online the
daily mail as well
um and i worked for 10 years at itv
daytime
as as well so that has led me to where i
am now
which is as a presenter on gb news the
new british
um 24-hour news channel and a columnist
on mail online or if you're from america
or
australia dailymail.com which is
obviously the biggest and best
most brilliant news website in the world
in my humble opinion yeah no one would
disagree
or some might but dan one of the things
that one of the reasons we were really
keen to get you on particularly i think
since
the the emergence of gb news is it was
so refreshing to see somebody on
mainstream television
putting articulately and intelligently
without hyperbole without overreacting
without
going into conspiracy the case against
some of the measures that the government
is taking on on covid on lockdown etc
and it was so refreshing and one of the
things that we wanted to ask you is
actually both francis and i come from
sort of authoritarian countries and so
we are hyper vigilant when government
starts going too far
what what first before we get into your
views exactly
what is it that drives you to be such a
strong opponent on some of these
restrictions that are
that we are seeing well to be honest i
didn't mention it actually when i was
just talking about my little career
history but i guess it was very
important to note that i
was on air on on talk radio hosting the
drive time
show there throughout the entire
pandemic i actually only took over the
show from eamon holmes
in february 2020 so literally with the
specter of covert 19 looming large
and obviously it was an incredible
opportunity professionally to be on air
at such a historic time and
so many people were listening to radio
because it was
a lifeline for people stuck in their
homes terrified
and i remember in in march 2020 and and
later i went back and and looked just to
to make sure that
you know that that my views had been
consistent but i remember saying at the
start of march 2020
in a democratic country like the uk
there's absolutely no way that we will
go down the path of
authoritarian china and that all of
these measures should be
voluntary and clearly we have to change
our behavior i was never denying that
there was a pandemic or that we
shouldn't stay home a bit more or that
certain things had to change
but i was so convinced especially with a
libertarian or so-called libertarian
prime minister that we would
not go down that path and obviously how
naive
i was but like most of the country
you know i reluctantly very reluctantly
and obviously this is all documented
because i was on
live for three hours a day apart from
the time when i contracted covert which
was just at the same time that boris
johnson did actually
but um i was very consistent in the fact
that
i'm not keen on this but okay three
weeks to save the nhs
fine let's do it so
i backed that first lockdown uh i wrote
my first
column against lockdown in
april 2020 so after about a month
and obviously that was at a time when
the media was still absolutely
enthralled with the idea that
restrictions needed to continue
uh so i certainly wasn't the first you
know peter hitchens in terms of the
mainstream media was the first and it
was fascinating
because when he wrote his column in the
mail on sunday the sort of first
big mainstream column about lockdown the
newspaper felt
they had to make it very clear that
this is our columnist's view but as a
newspaper we disagreed because
there was so much heat on anyone who was
speaking out against the government
message at that time
and from that moment in april 2020
i very quickly started to realize that
back in that first lockdown
was a massive mistake because those
freedoms that were taken away we we know
now
uh we're never easily going to come back
and so
you know i never defined what i was
other people then defined me as a
lockdown skeptic but i never viewed
myself that way i don't mind people
calling it that way but for me i was
just calling it as i
saw it and actually asking questions and
asking for evidence
and there was so little of that
forthcoming when was the moment
dan that you just thought hang on a
minute
it was actually in april when
i was walking home from work because i
was going into the office
every day so i'd had covered i'd had my
you know 10 days or whatever locked in
the house and i got back out
got back to work and i was walking home
because i would walk
every day home from the studio in london
bridge
which is where talk radio is based and
i got to the millennium bridge which is
the bridge in london which
leads over to saint paul's and
literally there was not a soul and i
actually
took that photo and the sun published it
large with my first so-called
anti-lockdown
column and i was just so disturbed i
just
it was so dystopian it's like this is
715
in what is usually the south bank of
london one of the
busiest parts of the world
and there's not a soul and what's
happened what's happened what does this
mean what is the impact going to be on
society
and i walked across the bridge and a
woman
who i was walking past literally
jumped to the other side of the bridge
to get away from me
and i just couldn't i saw then
what the government messaging was
already doing to people and and how
how damaging it was going to be and i
think it's that's absolutely proven to
be the case
and what would you say to people who go
look you know this is a pandemic this is
a disease
which you know is deadly for a large
percentage of the population the elderly
the
the vulnerable co-mobilities all of that
we need to do this
to protect them well
i later on so i think in october
i then became a signatory of the great
barrington declaration which is
uh the document uh put together by
dr j batacharya and and sinitra gupta
from oxford university brilliant huge
you know
medical brains who came up with a plan
to say there's a better way there's a
better way that we can protect the
vulnerable which was all about
focused protection of them in order for
society to keep going and
then we would have got to hurt immunity
and by now
a lot of this would be over i'm not
saying it would be gone covert is never
going to be gone is it it's going to be
with us for for our lifetimes but the
restrictions would be gone
so to the people who say that i would
say it doesn't
make sense it just doesn't make sense to
shut society down in the way that we did
for so many reasons
and also the collateral damage from
lockdown is going to be significant and
huge
for years to come and i've been so
disturbed at the lack
of focus from the media on the
collateral down i mean you only have to
look at the figures of people who died
in their homes
over that first lockdown in 2020
from heart attacks from strokes
i was speaking to doctors because i've
spoken to a lot of people
uh in the nhs over the course of the
past year who can't speak on the record
but are so disturbed with what happened
in the nhs and the shutdown that
happened i was literally speaking to
doctors who
who were talking to patients having a
stroke they knew they were having a
stroke and
they would not come into the hospital
because they were too scared of
contracting covert and obviously that
was because of the messaging so there's
never been a proper cost benefit
analysis done
of lockdowns i am convinced the
collateral damage
is going to be significant and huge for
years to come
and we needed to have a different
approach and look you look at other
countries that
are targeting a zero covert approach
like australia
and new zealand obviously i've got a lot
of relatives there
and i think they'll end up realizing
that the collateral damage that
they've done to their society even
though they've avoided covert
i will also be very significant so damn
what's going on then because here we are
three smart guys
you'd like to think we talked to other
smart people you've interviewed a bunch
of people we've interviewed a bunch of
people doctors
as you say every time we talk about
lockdown my
twitter inbox is flooded with messages
from doctors nurses people in nhs who
are saying
this you know a lot of the official
narrative is not true
we not everyone in the chest supports
everything that's happening
this doesn't seem to be about protecting
nhs anymore
so if if we're also clever and we're
also right
how is it that we're seeing these
polling numbers where the majority of
the public
will support seemingly anything
including beheading just to you know
keep things safe well i mean look
clearly if you spend
hundreds of millions of pounds on
propaganda and
that's a very loaded word and i don't
use it lightly
but the new zealand prime minister
jacinda ardern is on the record
describing the government's public
health messaging around covert as
propaganda you can see it in a video
and that is what a lot of the messaging
is about
and it's been everywhere and then it's
been everywhere in the mainstream media
all day every day on the bbc
on itv news on sky news and
the reality is that is still where the
vast amount of
people get their information and consume
uh their information every ad break on
every radio
station has been uh pumping out
terrifying messages
about covert and the damage of covert
and
you know when the government felt and
they still feel like they've lost
young people okay what can we do we're
going to try and terrify
young people about long covered and at
the moment the jury is out
on long covered there's actually clearly
it exists in in
some way but you know come on these days
they're saying
if you have erectile dysfunction it's
linked to long coverage
everything has been blamed on long
covered all of a sudden so i understand
how it is a lot of men in the 80s have
had long covers for a very long time
and when um people try and go down a
conspiracy theory past because
part because that's something i'm very
opposed to and i i
speak to intelligent people who are
saying look this has to be a conspiracy
theory that there's
there's no other way you know it's it's
well i'm not even going to repeat what
what they think but i'm like look this
is hanlon's razor you know this is about
incompetence and stupidity and complete
fear that has led to a complete
[ __ ] that's what this is
it's i mean no government could have
planned this i mean
that that's just extraordinary and
ridiculous
it's about fear it's about the media
it's all played into each other
and it's become a snowball effect
because look you know you look back
patrick valance was on the record last
march saying
that the government was trying to pursue
a herd immunity strategy
and that would have been sensible
because what did he say
he literally said on the record i mean
this was on the today program on the bbc
patrick balance if we do not pursue a
herd immunity strategy
now that was in march yes we're going to
try and slow the spread but we're not
going to try and completely compress the
spread of covet 19 because
it's okay if young people get it that
was his messaging
if we don't do that we will end up with
a
catastrophic second wave over the winter
what happened we abandoned the herd
immunity strategy we went for
government mandated laws to control our
behavior
and what did we have a catastrophic
second wave over the winter
now yeah it was bad in sweden too
it wasn't as bad and they didn't lose
their civil liberties and freedoms
and they also uh voluntarily
were able to change their behavior in
order to
compress the spread and actually what
that means is they have had
far less economic damage than we have
and we can never forget that poverty
leads to death
as well and people losing their jobs and
losing their businesses
leads to deaths as well so
yeah it's it's it's been difficult it's
been difficult to be on my side of the
argument it really has
uh because you know the moment that you
start
talking about some of these difficult
issues you're accused of being a
murderer or not caring about
80 year olds dying of covert and i do i
mean my great auntie died of covert in a
care home
but she died with covered
from dementia and the most horrific
thing about that is that none of us
could see her
in the months before she died she had no
understanding
of why her family were unable to see her
for months and months before she died
and
to me that is unforgivable it's tragic
it's it's it's awful it's awful that
she spent the last few months of her
life isolated from the people
who who love her the most yeah and she
and
you know she goes down as a as a death
from covert she died of dementia very
very serious dementia
with covert and we've never got our head
around
how we can talk about that how we can
break the statistics down
you know dominic cummings leaked text
messages that boris johnson had sent to
him
at some point uh during the summer or
late summer of 2020
where he was trying to have these
discussions with with dominic cummings
look
the average age from covert death in the
uk is 82
the average life expectancy in the uk is
81
and dominant coming says has released
these text messages to try and prove
that boris johnson is some sort of
pensioner killer and he doesn't care
about old people dying and
that's absolutely not the case he's
trying to make the point that
a lot of these people were going to die
because people die and it's absolutely
tragic and it's absolutely devastating
my auntie was over 82
and the the huge tragedy with her death
is the fact that we couldn't say goodbye
we couldn't give her a proper send-off
we couldn't have a proper funeral
and what that's putting people through
on on a daily basis to me is just so
wrong and and the issue is
that the media this is what i have tried
not to do
has shut down discussion about these
things so it shut down discussion about
the age of people who die from covert
it's shut down discussion about the
efficacy of masks
it's shut down discussion about whether
the virus
leaked from the lab in wuhan and
it's just been so shocking for me to
come back to your very original question
to live through this time and see
how the media is just not reporting
or is ignoring so many
absolutely crucial parts of the story
because yes the nhs is a crucial part of
the story and the nhs not been
overwhelmed as a crucial part of the
story
there's lots of other critical parts of
the story as well and they should all be
covered equally
hey kkk do you like feeling silky and
smooth like a
sexual dolphin never talk to me again
what if i told you that
manscape to brought out a new and
improved lawnmower
3.0 that allows you to be fresh
and shrimp for the ladies down below
i'm married the last time i was fresh
and trimmed down below jimmy savile
was a respected children's entertainer
i'm going to ignore that the lawnmower
has a cutting-edge ceramic blade which
reduces the risk of having an accident
where you least want an accident my bank
account no you idiot
you know los huevos oh right
plus it's waterproof which means you can
groom in the shower
and it has an led light so you can
really get an
accurate and precise trim excellent
sounds great what's the battery like 90
minutes
so you can do your whole area in about
seven recharges to take advantage of
this incredible offer go to manscape.com
and you'll get 20 off with free shipping
just use our code which is of course
trigger 2-0 that is trigger 2-0 that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscaped.com and use our code
which is of course tricker20
your boss will thank you excellent
dan so you and i are probably on the
same page in terms of conspiracy i'm not
into it
i'm you know i started the pandemic
being at zero percent interested in
conspiracy theories
half a year and i went to like 0.1 i
think i'm about 1
now but let me ask you this about the
media because you've explained and i
think you're absolutely right in
what you say and that the media are
shutting down discussion of certain
issues
why well number one the media
operates very well on fear so so that's
the first thing fair sales
and it was a very successful strategy
for them
number two ofcom because there were
really an offcom for people overseas as
is the uk regulator of the broadcast
media
and they put in i would say very
draconian
guidelines and rules about how covert
could be reported i think a lot of the
broadcasters took it very literally
which meant that they followed almost
slavishly
the government's guidelines public
health messaging
and then the third thing i would say is
politics because the media in the u.s
absolutely hated donald trump and they
wanted him out so what was the best way
to get donald trump out a pandemic where
they
ramped up the fear and blamed it all on
him and in the uk
too i mean the media has a loathing of
of boris johnson
and had a loathing of dominic cummings
and so i think those three
you know if i can sum it up very quickly
those three factors
combined and you say so three factors
combined well
it seems as if the shoe's on the other
foot now because
boris and his cronies are trying to shut
down the media
and its ability to report on them yeah
well i think
i think a couple of things happened
because boris johnson and the government
soon realized very early on i mean it
was
was around the time of the first
lockdown in march
we have to go with the media consensus
on this
because if we don't go with the media
consensus on this
we are going to be slaughtered on a
daily basis and we are going to be
blamed for
every single covert death in this
country
and the only way we're not going to be
blamed for a covert death is
is if we as if we locked down and we
locked on hard so that's the first thing
and then the second thing is yeah i mean
look i've worked in senior positions in
newspapers in the uk the idea that the
uk has a free media is just
absolutely ridiculous uh we don't you're
incredibly constrained as a journalist
here and and
i presume you're referring to the
proposed changes to the official secrets
act which will make it even easier for
journalists here to be prosecuted and
there is no public interest offence and
of course we have no first amendment
like the us and i think it's a
really bad time to be a journalist in
the uk dan you said
having worked in senior positions in
newspapers in this country which you
have
uh journalists are not free here why
because of the law so it's very easy
to sue in this country and people will
probably be
very familiar with a case where johnny
depp
sued me for something that i said about
him uh
in the sun newspaper in my column in the
sun newspaper
and it i was dragged through the courts
you know i was lucky that the sun and
news uk decided to
to back me in the case but if we'd lost
it would have cost millions and millions
of pounds so a lot of news organizations
simply cannot afford that
so so that's the first thing there's
lots of libel tourism here
there's no first amendment there's very
limited protection for journalists based
on freedom of speech
and it's really worrying you would
you would be shocked if you knew the
number of stories
that are simply not reported because
newspapers just
cannot even fathom the idea of taking
the legal risk and
you know there's qcs that are involved
there's lots of legal regulation
clearly after the phone hacking scandal
uh
in 2011 there needed to be a tightening
within newspapers of the internal
processes but you know
it's got worse and worse and worse and
there's obviously been
landmark privacy rulings in
in this country as well which mean
that internationally you're able to read
reports about
certain celebrities and their private
lives for example and in the uk
uk organizations are not able to publish
them
i mean that's already worrying but let's
talk a little bit about the legislation
that the government is trying to push
through at the moment
can you explain what is it and why is it
so dangerous to journalists
well it's so dangerous to journalists
because this reform to the official
secret sector and the government says
look we have to reform it because
it hasn't been changed since 1989 and
the entire world has changed and don't
worry
this isn't aimed and targeted at
journalists but it's all well and good
for
the government to say that but the
problem is is that there's no public
interest defense included as part of
this and without a public interest
defense there's actually
no way that a journalist can say
yes we did obtain
private security footage of matt
hancock breaking the law by
snogging his publicly paid for
staff member breaking covert
restrictions in his ministry of health
office
and we did obtain it via a contact and
maybe we even paid that contact i have
no idea if the sun
paid that contact or not uh but we did
do this
and there are legal question marks
around that but we did it because we
believe
the story was absolutely in the public
interest
to to publish and this law
does not include a public interest
defense so so
that's the concern dan and what uh
you know coming back to the sort of
conspiracy stuff very much in this vein
you you sort of you mentioned boris
johnson being
quote unquote for people listening i've
got both my hands up doing the quote
marks
libertarian what's happened to boris
johnson in the last 18 months
boris johnson's someone who wants to be
popular he wants to stay in power
he's easily influenced i think it's fair
to say
and sadly i think he's proven that he's
not a libertarian he was a libertarian
when it suited him and that was in
opposition
and especially when he was opposing tony
blair's
id card proposals and now that he's in
power
it's out the window you know and uh
look i because i do always try and look
at situations fairly and i actually
am not a boris johnson hater at all
you know i i think in some ways he's
been a brilliant prime minister in some
ways i absolutely love his style
and i love the way that he is very
nimble
and look he's he's done incredibly well
you know he's done incredibly well when
you when you compare
the absolutely catastrophic chaos and
carnage that surrounded theresa may's
government and
wow what a letdown she was you know the
new margaret thatcher
she had everything going for her and she
just couldn't do it so
i am not an outer an out and out hater
of of boris johnson and i do
understand uh that there were certain
things during the pandemic that it
probably would have been politically
impossible for him not to have done for
example to lock down the first time in
march 2020
but i knew that yeah there is about
coming you know
id papers health papers i mean this was
the man that said he would
eat his own id card of any iteration of
the state
ever asked him to produce it and
now he's trying to coerce young people
into being vaccinated or you're not
going to be able to go
to a nightclub i mean it's nuts and at
some point surely you have to
even in power actually just take a step
back and think
what is right you know nadeem zahawi the
vaccines minister i interviewed him
when i was on talk radio and i could see
vaccine passports coming and this was
you know december 2020
but i got him on video to give a cast
iron guarantee that they would
not be introduced and he did but he
actually went further than that
he described vaccine passports as
discriminatory and wrong
they were his words and now here he is
in parliament saying
they're inevitable almost i mean it's
it's worrying
it's worrying and the thing is at some
point you
have to lean back on your principles
don't you you just have to
and so i want to be able to support
boris johnson i think
most of the media want to do the
opposite you know they want to not
support him even
though he's now doing what much of the
liberal media are desperate for him
to have done if that makes sense
but at some point he's going to have to
stand up
against sage and the scientific
uh sort of monolithic view
uh who because that they're starting to
control
how we live with this body sage of
scientists it's nuts
and why look why a victim passport such
a bad idea there's a lot of people going
look
dan we're in a global pandemic you know
there's people that's going to die from
this
you know the vaccines stop people from
dying
they protect people what is wrong with
coercing people during a global pandemic
to take a vaccine with minimal risk
it's just about the slippery slope
towards a biosecurity state
in in my honest opinion that that's
where we're heading we see how the
chinese government
controls its population the social
credit scheme
and it's not that far from that
is it if you're saying to a perfectly
healthy young person
because you won't inject something into
your body which
i completely agree is is low risk but
there is a risk attached
and arguably there's a bigger risk
attached
than covert 19 which is why certain
regulators around the world
and australia for example uh have banned
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine for
anyone under
uh 40 and and obviously we did
two so
you know it's it's about the slippery
slope of of where this is going and you
know i'm
personally i'm very pro-medicine and i'm
very pro-vaccine and i have no
issues personally with trying
experimental medical products i never
have
right so my personal view is very
different to the view of lots of other
people who feel the same way as i do
about vaccine passports
but i just really fundamentally believe
that that has to be everyone's personal
decision
doesn't it what they what they put in
their body it's it's a personal choice
i have i guess quite uh
i'm quite into risk do you know what i
mean i'm prepared
to take a medical risk because i think
there's going to be lots of benefits but
i fully appreciate
that is everyone's right to make that
decision
themselves yeah i mean do you think that
they're going to go ahead
or do you think the tories are going to
capitulate i know it's an unfair
question no
i just i just think it feels inevitable
i think all of this feels inevitable i
think
another lockdown over winter feels
inevitable i think the reintroduction of
mandatory masks feels inevitable i think
the reintroduction of social distancing
feels inevitable i think the
reintroduction of curfews feels
inevitable i think the closing of
nightclubs and concerts at some point
over winter feels inevitable i think all
of this feels inevitable now
now obviously i hope i'm wrong and i'm
i'm actually genuinely desperate to be
proved
wrong um but you know throughout the
course of last year i didn't express
some of this stuff
publicly because i didn't want to add
into the the
the fair and i wanted to trust boris
when he said
no we're going to be okay for christmas
and you know but deep down i always knew
and i expressed privately that we would
spend all winter in lockdown and that
was one of the reasons i was raising
against it so much so
so this year i'm at a very different
place that i i want to call it out
because
if we don't and if we don't start
standing up against us because
fundamentally
the one thing that will end up changing
boris johnson's and the government's
position in this
is public opinion it's the one thing
that will change it so
i'm heartened to see polls now that say
actually people are fed up with the nhs
app and
are starting to delete it or considering
deleted i'm heartened by that because
again it's very difficult when you're
regulated by ofcom you can never
encourage anyone to break the law or
you'll be taken off air
but the nhs app is voluntary
you know the government might recommend
it but there's absolutely nothing
compelling you
at this point to download it for now
for now but it's a great way if you
don't want to go to work
well of course half a million people
great
of course ten days off totally totally
and i understand that